[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the columnist and broadcaster steve
richards and assistant comment editor at
the telegraph olivia upley so a very
good evening to both of you and pleased
to say that you'll both be with us till
midnight which is great
so let's take a look at what's on the
front pages of tomorrow's papers and you
won't be surprised at the times pictures
the queen beaming on the balcony during
the first day of the platinum jubilee
celebrations
likewise the daily telegraph heralds the
day as glorious showing the youngest
royal on the balcony covering his ears
as he stood with the queen during the
fly past
the mirror also has the moment that
prince louis covered his ears during the
fly past with the headline wow what a
racket great granny
away from the platinum jubilee the
guardian details alarm over women's
health as a result of nhs failing seeing
gynecology waiting lists rising to more
than half a million patients according
to a senior health leader
and the financial times has a story on
the opec oil group and its allies
agreeing to accelerate oil production in
the united arab emirates to overcome
russian shortages in the fallout from
russia's invasion of ukraine
and just a reminder that by scanning the
qr code that you can see on your screen
during the program you can check out
those front pages of tomorrow's papers
for yourself while you watch us
but right now let's bring in uh stephen
olivia to go through the papers and
steve no great surprise what's
dominating the front pages tomorrow
no surprise at all i i feel i might be
here on the wrong evening actually
because
i have to say from the beginning it
doesn't interest me i fully understand
many people are excited by it and
planning street parties for the rest of
it
i find it a bit bewildering and baffling
that this um
family uh unelected born into this role
are so revered but i know that that is
not a common view on a day like this and
many people
are kind of absolutely committed to
celebrating it and newspapers have to
reflect that and and they are but isn't
she we've got the times up on the screen
beaming queen gets her
party started but i understand she can't
make the saint paul's event tomorrow and
so on so
even though there is a kind of ebullient
euphoria in the coverage which i'm sure
reflects a lot of people's feelings
it there is actually an ambiguity even
in the event itself the fact that um
she's not going to be at all of it for
wholly understandable reasons a woman in
her mid-90s um but over to olivia who i
know is
much more excited by it than me well yes
olivia what do you make of what steve
said said there i mean do you see his
point or do you feel this is a moment of
history what's your feeling about it
well i don't blame steve at all for not
being interested in it himself but he's
absolutely right and saying that there
are an awful lot of people in the
country today who are very excited and
pleased to be watching this um the one
thing that really does unite this
country is we all love the queen um and
i think it's not it's it's it is about
the queen and it's wonderful celebrating
the queen and it's also wonderful
celebrating it feels like a full stop
mark really at the end of the covered
era watching everything back to normal
um this fantastic display uh one of the
commentators was saying you know we do
this pomp and pageantry better than any
other country it's just a sort of
glorious uh celebration of of this
country and seeing everyone back
together look at that crowded mall with
with everyone just just raising their
arms together uh i i think it's just a
fantastic day of celebration the first
glaten jubilee this country has ever
seen and possibly the last one too and i
think there is an element you know of of
this this is sort of the queen passing
on the battle and we're seeing less and
less of her as we've discussed she's not
going to be there um at the at the event
tomorrow um and so it's a good good
opportunity for the country to to say a
big thank you for for all those years of
service so i think it is a fantastic
brilliant celebration and i'm glad
people are enjoying it so much well yes
and and
as we saw in the times there a picture
of the queen smiling let's take a look
at the telegraph's front page as well
because again there's a picture of a
number of members of the royal family
smiling and prince louis meanwhile with
his hands uh on his ears complaining
about the noise of the fly past
steve
i mean will newspaper editors love a
story like this given that there are so
many colorful pictures and
a day where it offers so much in terms
of front page
pictures yeah i mean it's a sort of
humanizing image isn't it and of course
the younger
people in this family are innocent of
all that's going to
follow in the kind of weird lives that
they are doomed to lead and have no
choice but to
lead so it's a rather kind of vivid
family image kind of photo that uh could
happen to any
uh family but he said uh the reason i've
been with the wilderness i'm not saying
it in any kind of derogatory way i fully
get that people are engaged with this
but olivia said we all
love the queen but
we don't know her and i know that's part
of the mystery and the enigma is very
powerful
um
but
how
you know i just posed a question how how
can you love somebody you know i mean
i've actually met her probably olivia
has now she made me laugh says something
very
funny to me but
the the intensity of it i i i'm saying
it in all humilities i know many people
will disagree i find really
baffling
you know and i idolize people of talent
and things but these are
born into it um it's not a talent it's a
hereditary role
now she might have played it with great
dignity restraint and i fully appreciate
she's done it for many many years but
the level
of excitement over something which is in
reality so distant from people
i just find confusing but i completely
understand why newspapers are leading
with it and etc olivia
well i think that 70 years of totally
dedicated public service and public duty
is about the most admirable
thing imaginable like i can't think of a
better role model than the queen what
she's done for this country she served
day in day out and i would say doomed as
a funny word to use because it seems
like the royals are well today it looks
like royals are very much enjoying it
but i'm sure there have been times when
the queen hasn't wanted to go and cut
that ribbon to open that town fate or
whatever she happened to be doing on
some rainy day in a dark november in her
mid 70s but she turned up and she did it
every single day and she's brought so
much joy to all those people who who are
happy to see her there because they know
that their monarch cares about them i
would say that is the the best role
model anyone could possibly have and
well as you can tell
i'm a huge fan well yes steve what do
you make of that point the fact that she
has been queen through seven decades of
troubled times at times of of trauma for
many people i mean at the moment a lot
of the country is struggling with the
cost of living crisis there's the war in
ukraine going on as well
do you think though can you see that
some people see that that sense of
constancy as as
some kind of of support to them in some
way
i can see it completely
but i don't understand it i mean i you
know she will have no role in the cost
of living crisis and it's very
interesting
when uh these events are described as
historic when you look back for example
the silver jubilee in the late 70s i
think it was 1977
the kind of history of that period is
all about actually stuff that we're
living through again now you know
inflation winter of discontent all that
kind of thing
which was about how elected politicians
responded and held to account in
elections and so on
this kind of is is far removed from all
of that and the reality of um
people's lives but maybe that's part of
the exciting the the distance and the
fact that there is absolutely no
connection with actual people's lives
and the cost of living is it is part of
the explanation for
the reverence and excitement
and and everything but on the sense of
duty it it is obviously emphatically
there but but there are many other kind
of dutiful figures in the world you know
in britain um
so i i
olivia's very persuasive but i remain
skeptical and olivia let's take a look
at the mirror shall we because they've
also go with that shot of of prince
louis covering his ears and and the
queen
smiling um on their front page and lots
of balcony shots as well i mean we
talked about
sense of duty but also there's a real
sense of family here isn't there and a
lot of people were looking at the
balcony shots as well and reflecting on
who wasn't there as well as he was there
who was
yeah i thought it was uh a very
interesting i mean i love seeing the the
little cambridges up there and princess
charlotte you can see her there she's um
she's such a natural sort of star i
think that alice and alison pierson
mentions this in a telegraph piece
biggest natural star since diana and i
think she's definitely got some of
diana's jeans there um and prince louis
just being so sort of natural and and
sweet and charming you know ordinary
little little four-year-old destined for
for this fantastic extraordinary kind of
life um and i think you also see the
sense here of of as i was saying earlier
sort of passing on of the baton
sometimes you've seen that balcony
stuffed full of all sorts of minor oils
and today we've seen this kind of
slimmed down royal family which i think
is generally where we're heading a
slightly more uh yeah a smaller version
of the of the extended royal family
can't just keep getting bigger um and
also we see that line of succession very
clearly um you've got charles downstairs
doing the pageant himself um but you've
got on that balcony the queen uh prince
william and um oh sorry maybe it was
kate but but and george as well so all
of those generations um and in that you
can see the kind of constancy of the
monarchy and then you've got that lovely
moment where where the queen leans down
and and talks to prince louis i think
about uh the flypath that's going on
which planes are involved um and you can
just see those generations passing
through and and you know 96 year old
queen with the with her four-year-old
great-grandson um which represents in
itself the the future and the past and
the future of the monarchy uh it's quite
an amazing quite an amazing shot really
indeed and um there will be a lot of
column inches inside the papers as well
devoted no doubt to the first day of
four so papers no doubt will have lots
to go on the days ahead sorry about that
steve
we're going to take a break right now
lots of other stories around of course
as well that we'll get our teeth into in
just a moment including the financial
times which is reporting on how the opec
oil group is set to help ease rising oil
prices more on that in a moment
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview uh with me tonight are the
columnist and broadcaster steve richards
and assistant comment editor at the
telegraph olivia utley so welcome back
to both of you and we're going to kick
off this section with the guardian and
the guardian have put a huge picture
haven't they olivia of the balcony today
and the start of the platinum jubilee
celebrations but their main story is on
something completely different you can
see their alarm at nhs failings over
women's health so talk us through
what this exclusive as they bill it says
well it's very alarmingly exclusive half
a million women are waiting for uh
treatment for women's health issues and
the story is that women's health is
being routinely
uh
un
under underplayed basically um it's
known all sorts of conditions are called
benign conditions including
endometriosis but plenty of other
very serious gynological conditions
benign in the sense that they're not
cancerous
but in plenty of ways you know
endometriosis is far from benign
and in some cases can be lethal
so the guardian and
lots of campaigners here are calling for
an end to the use of that word um and
for more funding and expertise to be put
into women's health which is a
historically very overlooked area of
medicine um it's hoped that there are
going to be centers across the country
for women's health exclusively uh in in
the coming years and the government's
going to put white paper but it's all a
bit hazy um and it's a it's a very
important story and it's good that the
guardian is pushing it today well yes
and steve as olivia hinted out there the
government has got this health strategy
pending for england um to address some
of these women's health issues do you
feel confident that the kind of scale of
the issue is has been taken on board
not wholly no
and this has a wider application
um i mean there's been this national
insurance rise which was in theory to
pay for social care but in the short
term it's going to pay for the shortfall
in nhs funding and it boys it need i
mean the guardian story is one example
of many
and in a way because so much else is
going on you know ukraine and the future
of boris johnson's song
this health story has been submerged a
bit and it's good the guardian are
splashing on one element of it the
urgency of treatment for
women and whether the waiting list is
such that the treatment can sometimes
not be
addressed in the time that it's needed
to be addressed and that applies to many
other areas as well
and i think this is going to become in
the run-up to the next general election
a huge story
um these vast waiting lists
and uh the government be under huge
pressure to get them down but of course
that means increased staff and where
they're going to get staff from and that
takes time
and anyway this extra money is only
meant to be temporary because it's all
meant to go on
so
it's a very messy situation lots of
questions ahead let's take a quick look
at the front natural times main story as
well olivia they're saying that opec is
going to boost their output of oil um in
attempt to try and uh cool the price
down a bit
yeah it's a pretty bit of a sticky
situation that europe has got itself
into for years and years that
almost no country in europe has had a
sort of sensible energy strategy the
strategy has been to make it look as
though we're going green by by basically
outsourcing our energy production mainly
to russia so and a lot huge swathes of
europe are very heavily dependent on
russian energy and germany being a prime
example you can see
schultz flip-flopping at the moment not
quite sure what to do because he is so
dependent um and now obviously there are
these sanctions against against russia
which is in part exacerbating the cost
of living crisis and the saudis are now
offering to to plug that gap basically
which is you know far from ideal we
don't want to be reliant on putin but we
don't want to be reliant on on saudi
arabia either uh so it feels as though
europe is is sort of reaping
reaping what we sowed with with a very
very poor uh
energy strategy over over decades really
well yes and underlying this just in 20
seconds steve this whole issue that the
higher the price of all the worse our
cost of living crisis is
yeah it's all interconnected the energy
shortage is caused partly by ukraine
that fuels inflation so in the short
term it probably is good news if um opec
is increasing its oil productivity but
it's only a short term okay solution
very fundamental problem absolutely well
we are going to say thank you for now
but you will be back with us at 11 30.
but uh stephen olivia thank you for the
moment